finally here we go good evening here oh
you have 500 and the dick popular
combination - I can keep that - yeah son
fit me some plays only retreat next
mission we'll call you alright it's not
a hug from - scram the top way all right
there yet
alright good good luck out there
hey Peter you're on tonight I can't
tonight I got the start internship
what's up guys
mister sir here's my report for tonight
I stopped the grandstand flights go hey
could you do me a favor hold on to that
there's anybody by I helped this old
lady and she bought me a churro
so how was nice I just feel like I could
be doing more wait a minute you guys on
the real event just hope gives it away
you move them working on some better
he's working for crazy dangerous mr.
Tator there people who handle the sort
of man can't you just be a friendly
neighborhood spider-man
the world's changing boys timely change
too
I can't prove myself you Spanish queens
you got to get better at this part of
the job oh I'm dating
where you going what are you hiding
Peter I'm just kidding Unger bye
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocols because mister
start treating me like a kid could you
are a kid yeah you can stop a boss with
his bare hands
surprise surprise everybody
early morning spider-man trailers
dropping there's two of them so I'll do
another video for the other one after
this but they're just hyping up way more
scenes more perspective and we learn all
about the AI in the spider-man suit the
Iron Man version of a Spider Man suit
you can call it iron spider if you want
they very clearly say that a bunch of
the systems are in the training wheels
modes that are unlockable only with Tony
Stark's approval so I'll say new round
of the Spider Man giveaway is for the
action figures there are so many things
that they are going to be turning into
toy sets in this it's crazy but it
actually looks really cool so let's just
start with the beginning of the footage
and work our way through so starting
with the AI suit he powers it on I love
the light scheme it just totally lights
up so a lot of you are wondering about
this blue version of the Spider Man suit
it probably just has light panels that
light up and change depending on what
mode the suit is in the way they're
billing it is it'll probably just get
upgrade through software the Tony Stark
gives it and hardware so during infinity
war it'll do a lot of cool things but
it'll still look like the traditional
Spider Man suit in if they really want
to get crazy they could always make a
symbiote black version of the costume
that had just turned black instead of
him having to climb out of it and climb
into a different suit if you missed some
of the Marvel comics right after secret
war the new version of the suit that
Iron Man built for himself was just
modular it would become any kind of suit
that he needed so like in this movie
he's wearing the ultimate color scheme
from the ultimate Iron Man costume
the newest suit could turn into the Hulk
buster if he wants it could turn into
the stealth suit but it's one suit he
doesn't climb in and out of different
suits so it just sounds like that's
what's going on with the new spider-man
suit and even bigger the first time that
they've ever done this is that Iron Man
style they're filming his perspective
inside the costume so we've never seen
that before in a spider-man movie the
Iron Man movie was one of the first
times that they did that in the Marvel
Universe but now they're passing that on
you can see how they changed it a little
bit it's a little bit clearer display
there's not quite as much junk going on
but there are five hundred plus
different web shooter configurations
that he has so this is just the
beginning we've seen the web wings we
see a look at the drone so the drone
just feeds information into the suit
we'll probably see it pop up on its
heads-up display
you see him get dropped off by Tony
Stark there's the case that they carry
the suit around in him walking past
Midtown high just walking through the
hallways net leads comes up hey you
coming tonight so there's this balance
of high school life along with the
hopeful Avengers like that he's trying
to leave so he says he's busy with his
dark internship and then goes out trying
to help people just like this comedy
montage I say people from a bike jacking
he keeps calling Tony Stark over and
over
mission report helped an old lady she
bought me a churro it was awesome you
even see a nod to the Tobey Maguire
spider-man with him riding on the front
of the Train here just bothering Iron
Man over and over every chance he gets
you have to remember that he's busy with
Stark Industries he's a billionaire he
has a giant company he has the real-life
Avengers that he's trying to manage so
then you get a much longer version of
this Bank save where you see him go up
against all these shatori based weapons
they pick up one of the cutting weapons
and it just slices all the way through
the building just letting you know how
crazy powerful some of these weapons the
vulture is manufacturing with the help
of the tinkerer but it blows up the
bodega so you get some more context for
some of these scenes he goes to see Iron
Man to try and tell them about what's
going on out in Queens
look these weapons are crazy dangerous
Iron Man's like dude just be a kid we
have people that handle that kind of
stuff that's what the Avengers are for
dealing with flying bird men but I love
the way he's standing in the Avengers
tower here you see him standing against
the backdrop of the a just like one more
year around this time next year we're
going to be watching infinity war he
will probably be an Avenger by that time
you see the Quinn jet fly off he tells
them about being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man and you get a much bigger
version of the ferris bueller scene of
them running through the backyards
chasing each other where the vulture
just grabs him right out of midair it
sounds like from the sue day I just
kicking on that it has a version of
autopilot it might not be quite as fully
functional as Jarvis but it sounds like
it has a lot of things just built in to
help him just because he has no idea
what's going on part of the training
wheels mode that they discover we get a
much better look at the vultures
facility probably the best look at the
harness that we've gotten so far
human net leads getting ready to go on
their big field trip to the Washington
Monument
you finally see
Glover you know you're not very good at
this kid you should probably work on
that a little bit as you swing through
the backyards I like the way they cut
this is he swings off of this tree house
brings it crashing down scares the crap
out of those little girls but you get a
better look at the drone and then a
scene that looks like it's from much
later in the film this is probably one
of the final boss fights just because
he's wearing the old version of the
costume and it looks like this is well
after Tony Stark has taken the suit back
changing into his costume where are you
going Peter just kidding I don't give a
crap then a whole bunch more of the
fairy save I love this dude here yes
butter man like the legend of spider-man
has already spread even though he's only
been spider-man for a very brief period
but let me know biggest question they
find out about the training wheels mode
there are a whole lot of subsistence
here Peter but it says they're on
lockdown what do you think that some of
those are I have a feeling that they'll
withhold some of the really cool ones
for infinity war in the second
spider-man Home Coming movie but like a
lot of the stuff that the suit does he
has no idea about he doesn't know about
all the different web shooter
configurations yet he probably didn't
know about that parachute or even the
drone inside the emblem so just think
about all the really cool things that it
can do in the different looks that it
can give off like the spider light is
just one thing that we haven't seen in
one of the trailers yet but we saw him
playing with the gauntlet at the end of
civil war but there is so much Avengers
that's integrated into this movie they
really want you to feel like part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
and there's another international
trailer with all different footage that
I'll do a video for that has even more
Avenger stuff going on in it so on out
the winner of the giveaway when I post
that that should be up later this
morning
while you wait for that click here for
brand new flash from last night's finale
and you can click here for more
spider-man homecoming thank you so much
for watching let's high-five I'll see
you guys in the next video